time is running out we are facing a
serious crisis in the country and what
we need to do is to find a way forward
away out of this which is why I support
a confirmatory referendum because the
offer to the prime minister is you can
have your deal as long as you put it to
the British people
Jeremy Corbyn and Kirsten mer and Emily
Thornberry all say that labour supports
a confirmatory referendum it was at the
end of the policy that in terms of
process that the Labour Party conference
agreed back in October it is
overwhelmingly supported by Labour Party
members and therefore because we're at
this point all this legislation all of
this uncertainty the Prime Minister
having to reach out this is all because
Parliament has not been able to reach
agreement on a way forward and the great
merit of a confirmatory referendum which
is why it is Labour's policy is that it
would enable a final decision to be made
because this cannot carry on the public
are losing confidence in the political
process we cannot keep on showing that
we are deadlocked and the beauty of
going back to the British people as you
could say you don't have to change your
mind you can vote to leave because this
is what a leave deal looks like it's the
only one that's been negotiated or on
the other hand if you want to change
your mind you're free to do so